und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf uns marietta slomka
guten abend die geschichte der
belarussischen sprinterin christina
tiemann of fire erinnert an sowjetzeiten
und kalten krieg eine sportlerin die
sich absetzt weil sie angst hat vor dem
was ihr in der heimat bot wie schon
zehntausende andere landsleute vor er
flüchtet sie nach polen warschau hat
inzwischen eine große belarussische
dissidenten community so groß ist die
sorge um das wohlergehen der athleten
dass die polnischen behörden sie
kurzfristig auf einen anderen flieger
buchten und über wien nach warschau
reisen ließen jetzt am abend ist sie
dort eingetroffen
eine junge sportlerin die plötzlich zu
einem politikum geworden ist einer
anderen frau maria kohl s nikkor wird
jetzt in minsk der prozess gemacht sie
ist eine der drei frauen die den kampf
der belarussischen opposition anführten
heute war auf sagt jeder veranstaltung
die das regime als gerichtsverhandlung
bezeichnet für begab berichtet maria
callas und ecowas botschaft zu
prozessbeginn
wir lieben euch alle hören sie auf zu
reden lautet die prompte antwort der
belarussischen justiz nach elf monaten
untersuchungshaft tanzt kulissen koffer
sie lächelt und formt ihr markenzeichen
das herz vor dem gerichtsgebäude wartet
der vater der oppositionellen auf
neuigkeiten
ich bewundere der mensch der prozess
findet ohne unabhängige medien ohne
zuschauer statt das wusste alexander
kalaschnikow schon als wir ihn vor
einigen tagen in linz betreffen ja was
bringe ich sehe das als einen weiteren
hinweis auf die schwäche des regimes auf
seine furcht vor dem eigenen volk vor
denen die aktiv sind und anders denken
so benötigt
verstehen sie dass es derart
offensichtlich dass man manchmal fast
darüber lachen
im sommer 2020 ist maria callas nico war
teil des frauen trios das diktator
lukaschenko herausfordert anfang
september will der geheimdienst sie
außer landes bringen valess die koffer
zerreißt ihren pass will unbedingt in
belarus bleiben
dort drohen ihr jetzt zwölf jahre haft
er komponiert muss das urteil steht von
vornherein sitzung soll für die
staatsmacht geht es mit den prozessen
nur darum die illusion eines
gerichtsverfahrens zu verbreiten
in den letzten wochen ist der druck auf
die zivilgesellschaft in belarus noch
einmal gestiegen hier die verhaftung
einer dudelsack gruppe die vor einem
jahr bei protesten ein lied namens
veränderung gespielt hatte dort über 50
verbote von
nichtregierungsorganisationen
allein seit anfang juli obdachlosen und
waisenkindern halb das projekt von
katharina kissel war bis lukaschenko das
nicht mehr gefiel details das regime
versucht an der macht zu bleiben
und räumt deswegen alles was es als
potenzielle bedrohung ansieht aus dem
weg unter diese plagne walze sind wir
alle geraten
die großen proteste wurden zerschlagen
der drang nach demokratie aber lebe
weiter ist sich kulissen ecowas vater
sicher unsere jugend hat ihre
weltanschauung verändert
sie versteht ihre ziele und aufgaben
deswegen bin ich überzeugt dass die
protestbewegung noch immer träumen sie
von einem freien belaruskali seehofer
kürzlich
wann das urteil gegen sie fällt ist
nicht bekannt wie lukaschenko mit seinem
eigenen volk umgeht ist die eine seite
der medaille
zugleich tritt aber auch gegenüber
anderen ländern als aggressor auf die
quasi entführung eines europäischen
passagierflugzeugs gab dann nur einen
vorgeschmack der bäder russische
geheimdienst kgb agiert auch anderweitig
ungeniert auf ausländischem boden
im russischen stil sozusagen und
inzwischen betreibt lukaschenko offenbar
regelrechten menschenhandel
er lässt flüchtlinge vor allem aus dem
irak nach belarus einfliegen und dann an
die grenze zu litauen bringen um das
kleine nachbarland sind die bredouille
zu bringen und die eu insgesamt zu
erpressen
für januar berichtet sind das
geflüchtete die schutz suchen oder
menschen die für den racheakt eines
diktators missbraucht werden es sind auf
jeden fall bilder die das litauische
innenministerium veröffentlicht sie
sollen zeigen wie ein jeep in belarus
menschen bis kurz vor die litauische
grenze schickt dann zurücksetzt die
menschen sollen offenbar in litauen um
asyl bitten
wofür die zuständige eu innenkommissarin
auf orts besuch in litauen selten
deutliche worte findet das ist nicht in
erster linie an die migrations krise das
ist ein akt der aggression der
provozieren sollen es ist der jüngste
akt einer beispiellosen eskalation im
osten europas aus der einen seite der
belarussische diktator lukaschenko der
einen regimekritischen blogger im mai
auf europäischem boden entführen lässt
auf der anderen seite die europäische
union die darauf ungewöhnlich schnell
mit harten sanktionen reagiert
sanktionen auf die lukaschenko nun
offenbar antwortet seit wochen
beobachten eu diplomaten wie die zahl
der direktflüge aus bagdad und istanbul
nach belarus drastisch zunimmt und wie
belarus die menschen aus diesen fliegern
gezielt nach litauen weiter schickt über
die grüne kaum gesicherte grenze
und so sind sie jetzt da tausende meist
irakische flüchtlinge in überfüllten
litauischen lagern ihre chancen auf
politisches asyl mögen klein sein ihre
hoffnungen sind es nicht
europa soll uns helfen
wir müssen in ein anderes land litauen
uns nicht will
lasst mich ziehen in ein besseres leben
also von liza und weiter in andere
eu-staaten lukaschenko trifft europa
genau dort wo es sich in den letzten
jahren schon
kaum ein ich wurde an seinem wunden
punkt ein system zur verteilung von
flüchtlingen gibt es nicht immer noch
nicht auch nicht nach jahren der
flüchtlingskrise wir werden auch nicht
drum herumkommen diesem kleinen land zu
helfen das heißt andere größere
mitgliedsstaaten der eu müssen in diesem
falle auch für diejenigen die ein
anrecht einer perspektive in der eu
haben quoten zur verfügung stellen was
man in berlin wohl ahnt aber besser
öffentlich nicht vorab versprechen will
sobald eine konkrete anfrage vorliegt
werden die eu und die mitgliedstaaten
diese anfrage natürlich prüfen nicht
prüfen lässt sich was diktator
lukaschenko heute den litauischen
grenzbeamten vorwirft flüchtlinge zu
misshandeln
ein irakischer flüchtlinge so erklärt
zumindest dass bilder russische
präsidentenamt sei gar an den folgen der
misshandlungen gestorben
jetzt ermittelt das regime das selbst so
wenig zimperlich mit kritikern umgeht
also wegen mordes vorwürfe die litauen
empört zurückweist
sicher ist heute nur so viel dass sich
da zwei groß krisen europas treffen die
um belarus und die um flüchtlinge auf
den tag ein jahr ist es her dass sind
bei rot die hölle ausbrach
100 tonnen exklusives ammonium
ammoniumnitrat flogen im hafen der stadt
in die luft durch die gewaltige
detonation wurden ganze stadtteile
zerstört hunderttausende wurden
obdachlos und selbst von 200 menschen
verloren ihr leben
an jedem ort der welt wäre das ein
furchtbares unglück gewesen
mit berod traf es eine stadt die aber eh
schon gebeutelt war durch die unendlich
vielen probleme die der libanon hat
wirtschaftskrise kriegsvergangenheit
politische instabilität korruption
da wundert es nicht dass auch
wiederaufbau und aufklärung der
unglücksursache nicht vorankommen
in der bevölkerung wächst die wut
darüber uli gack berichtet aus beirut
feuerwehrmann rami kg wird seine safa
nur noch als erinnerung bleiben
jahrestag der explosionskatastrophe
hauptwache offizielles gedenken an die
neuen feuerwehrmänner und die
rettungsassistentin die man vor einem
jahr zu dem brandherd im hafen geschickt
hatte in ihren sicheren tod wie man
heute weiß niemand bei der feuerwehr
wusste von dem explosiven ammoniumnitrat
im hafen sagt man uns hier nie im leben
sagt ins safa rettet sie vorstellen
können dass alle hohen libanesischen
politiker von der existenz des spreng
mittels wussten und es für sich
behielten
das waren unschuldige männer die voller
hingabe und liebe ihre aufgabe erfüllt
haben und dann auf kriminelle
machenschaften
die stände sind als der ehemann starb
war sie gerade schwanger den jungen hat
safar nach seinem vater genannt rami er
ist neun monate alt knapp 100 dollar
rente haben sie und die beiden kinder
monatlich zum überleben
das reicht nicht hinten und nicht vorne
es gibt keinen strom es gibt kein wasser
die währung ist am boden die politiker
sind gegen dich das ganze land
kollabiert
es ist das erste mal dass sofa den ort
besucht in dem ihr mann gestorben ist
sie fürchtet den tag sagt sie
an dem sie ihren kindern die wahrheit
sagen muss dass ihr vater von
kriminellen politikern und skrupellosen
beamten in einen sinnlosen tod die
schichten möglich
diese enorme zerstörung anzusehen tut
mir sehr weh weil ich mir vorstellen
muss was hier mit meinem mann spaziert
ist die guten leute sind gestorben was
für ein zufall dass niemand wichtiges
von dem verwaltungsmanagement zu diesem
zeitpunkt gewartet da sie will kämpfen
wie gerechtigkeit für ihren mann seine
kollegen und die sanitäterin auch wenn
das in diesem libanon in diesem durch
und durch korrupten land wie sie sagt
eigentlich ein ding der unmöglichkeit
ist und schalten wir noch zu unserem
korrespondenten in peru sac problem
wie erlebst um die stadt in diesen tagen
es ist im prinzip die ganze bandbreite
dazwischen tiefer niedergeschlagenheit
und ohnmächtigen sohn niedergeschlagen
deshalb weil mir viele leute sagen es
wird sich hier nie was ändern da ist die
hisbollah die wird vom iran aus
gesteuert alle anderen parteien machen
je nach dem geschäfte mit der hisbollah
wies eben gerade passt und es wird sich
eben deshalb nie in diesem land
irgendwie politisch was ändern
eine tiefe ohnmacht fühlen viele deshalb
auch weil diese politische klasse nicht
nur die eine juristische untersuchung
dieses diese katastrophe unterbindet
sondern weil sie sie geradezu sabotiert
es wird sich nicht ändern sagen uns
viele es wird alles immer nur schlimmer
noch werden die preise werden weiter
steigen die geldentwertung nimmt zu die
us-mutter wasser für strom bezahlen was
vorher in diesem umfang nicht möglich
war
die leute haben kein geld mehr und mit
wem wir reden die wollen alle nur noch
weg aus diesem land sie haben in libanon
keine hoffnung mehr
alle jungen sagen uns nach amerika nach
europa australien egal wohin nur nicht
im libanon bleiben
eindrücke aus beirut dankeschön uli gack
in tschechien hat es heute ein schweres
zugunglück gegeben in das auch ein aus
münchen kommende zug verwickelt war und
damit beginnen die nachrichten dann halt
wolf bei dem unglück nahe der deutschen
grenze kamen drei menschen ums leben
darunter die beiden lokführer
nach ersten erkenntnissen über fuhr ein
aus münchen kommende expresszug offenbar
zwei warnsignale und kollidierte
daraufhin mit einem tschechischen
regionalzug vier deutsche verletzte
wurden in bayerische krankenhäuser
gebracht die ermittlungen zur
unfallursache laufen derzeit noch
in mehreren ländern am mittelmeer
kämpfen die menschen weiter gegen
verheerende waldbrände neue feuer sind
heute in den besonders betroffenen
regionen in griechenland und der türkei
ausgebrochen
nur 30 kilometer nordwestlich von athen
kämpfen hunderte feuerwehrmänner gegen
die flammen
über 300 menschen wurden in sicherheit
gebracht etliche wohnhäuser sind bereits
niedergebrannt schwere rauchverbot ab
und zu den hohen feinstaubwerten kommen
noch temperaturen von über 40 grad
auch im süden der türkei bleibt die lage
dramatisch am achten tag in folge bieten
dort waldbränden wohngebiete sind akut
gefährdet und ein kraftwerk wurde von
den flammen erfasst durch sengende hitze
und starker winde breiten sich die feuer
rasend schnell aus der deutsch-iranische
außenpolitiker der grünen omid nouripour
hat von der deutschen politik und der
europäischen union mehr härte im umgang
mit iran gefordert
dessen neuer präsident ibrahim reich sie
der morgen sein amt antritt sei ein blut
richter der für den tod aber tausende
häftlinge verantwortlich seid sagte
nouripour dem zdf es geht nicht um
sanktionen die alle in der breite
treffen aber ganz viele in diesem system
haben beispielsweise konnten in europa
weiterhin lassen ihre kinder hier
studieren den weh zu tun denen zu klar
zu machen dass wir sie auf dem kieker
haben dass wir nicht einfach sie machen
lassen wie sie lust haben das wäre ein
riesenschritt nach vorne das ganze
gespräch läuft nachher im heutigen
update und in der mediathek die militant
islamistischen taliban haben sich zu dem
anschlag in der afghanischen hauptstadt
kabul bekannt bei dem gestern mindestens
13 menschen ums leben kamen
wegen der explosionen in kabul wurde
nach angaben des bundesinnenministeriums
eine ursprünglich für gestern abend
geplante abschiebung mehrere afghanische
männer von münchen nach kabul
kurzfristig abgesagt sie solle aber bald
nachgeholt werden
deutschland gibt erste corona impfdosen
für andere länder mit akutem bedarf ab
sofort und bis auf weiteres werden alle
lieferungen des herstellers astrazeneca
an die internationale hilfsinitiative
kovacs gespendet wie das
bundesgesundheitsministerium heute
bekannt gab
zur krone lage in deutschland das robert
koch institut meldet 3571 neuinfektionen
binnen 24 stunden 803 mehr als
vergangenen mittwoch 25 menschen starben
innerhalb eines tages im zusammenhang
mit cupid 19
die sieben tage incidents liegt bei 18 5
doch wie aussagekräftig sind diese
zahlen noch vor allem die sieben tage
incidents das sorgt inzwischen für
diskussionen und soviel sei vorweg
gesagt die sache ist nicht so einfach
der hauptnutzen des incidents wertes
lacker darin ein zwar größer aber doch
recht guter frühindikator zu sein weil
es einen engen zusammenhang zwischen
incidents und krankenhauseinweisungen
gab
der wird aber natürlich schwächer in dem
maße in dem menschen geimpft sind
bisher sind aber nur rund 50 prozent der
bevölkerung vollständig geimpft
so gesehen ist die aktuelle incidents
für die ungeimpfte hälfte eigentlich
sogar höher
andererseits ist die impfquote bei den
risikogruppen höher
das muss man natürlich auch mit
einbeziehen und dem gegenüber steht
wiederum das argument dass das virus
noch recht unerforscht ist
und janko wird offenbar auch jüngere
menschen mit milden verläufen
nachträglich treffen kann
kurzum sie merken dass incidents thema
ist wirklich schwierig die politik muss
das aber irgendwie lösen denn die
debatte darüber ist längst in vollem
gange elisabeth schmidt berichtet
salzgitter großstadt im harzvorland
würde gerne anders in die schlagzeilen
kommen präsident 68 spitzenreiter in
deutschland in den vergangen
tagen zwar ist die inzidenz heute leicht
zurückgegangen liegt aber den vierten
tag in folge über 50
laut corona verordnung heißt dass
restaurants oder theater dürfen nur die
hälfte ihrer plätze belegen wechsel
unterricht an den schulen doch die
akzeptanz dieser corona maßnahmen
schwindet ich kann es auch nicht
verstehen denn die leute sind ja
inzwischen gilt jedenfalls die gefährdet
sind
warum lassen sie die menschen nicht
einfach wieder ganz normal leben
es kommen immer wieder einschränkungen
wird wieder revidiert wird wieder noch
was dazu gesetzt
dritter impfung jetzt noch mal
zusätzlich dass es irgendwann mal reicht
wir haben die schnauze voll wirklich
also irgendwann ist es auch gut
die inzidenz geht darauf das komplette
gesellschaftliche leben wird automatisch
runter gefahren an diese strikten corona
regeln will sich salzgitters
oberbürgermeister nicht mehr halten das
ist weder zeitgemäß noch ist es
verantwortungsvoll ich die interessen
gesundheitsschutz mit den anderen
interessen wie persönlichkeitsrechte wie
recht auf ausübung eines gewerbes
bildungsrecht auch abwägen muss ich muss
immer das risiko bewerten können
wie schwer sind auch verläufe von
erkrankung das ist auch mittlerweile
anders als vor drei vier monaten in
salzgitter steckten sich zuletzt viele
über private kontakte an nur dort
verschärft die stadt jetzt die korona
maßnahmen ein haushalt darf sich nur
noch mit zwei personen eines weiteren
haushalts treffen schulen gastronomie
kultur und sport werden dagegen nicht
eingeschränkt der oberbürgermeister hält
eine grundsätzliche debatte über coroner
maßnahmen für nötig die incident zum
alleinigen maßstab machen halte ich
jetzt für falsch auch in berlin wird
gestritten rki-chef wieder will an der
inzidenz als light indikator festhalten
der bundesgesundheitsminister
widerspricht mit steigender impfrate so
sparen
verliert die inzidenz an aussagekraft
zahlreiche wissenschaftler sehen das
ähnlich
die pure incidents korreliert heutzutage
aufgrund der impfungen nicht mehr mit
der intensivbetten belegung oder den
todesfällen
weil einfach durch die impfung
entsprechend die menschen geschützt sind
vor schweren verläufen
und daher ist die inzidenz als
alleiniger parameter nicht mehr
zeitgemäß die impfquote die zahl
positiver corona tests und die
intensivbetten belegungen müssten mit
berücksichtigt werden
es stellen sich aber auch ethische
fragen wie gerecht ist es noch allen
bürgerinnen und bürgern freiheiten zu
entziehen wenn sich hauptsächlich
ungeimpfte infizieren und dadurch die
inzidenz steigt es ist tatsächlich so
dass sie weiter wie jetzt in der
pandemie voranschreiten desto
passgenauer sollten die maßnahmen seien
und das kann geografisch seien ja dass
wir das nur lokal einsetzen das kann
aber auch seine unterscheidung in
geimpften und ungeimpften so dass wir
also gucken müssen dass wir so wenig wie
möglich maßnahmen verlängern verhängen
und so passgenau wie möglich salzgitter
möchte das testen
die stadt will einen neuen weg im umgang
mit dem virus gehen möglicherweise
beispielhaft für ganz deutschland
nächste woche wird es wieder eine bund
länder runde geben eine sogenannte mpk
wurde er es ja schon so einige gab in
dieser pandemie der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat dafür ein
diskussionspapier ausgearbeitet das
ahnen lässt in welche richtung es im
herbst gehen könnte grundsätzliche
maßnahmen wie maske tragen innenraum
sollen erhalten bleiben
auf ungeimpfte könnten einschränkungen
zu kommen etwa dass sie sich testen
lassen müssen bevor sie ins kino oder
restaurant dürfen und die tests dann
auch selbst bezahlen müssen
auch an den schulen soll es weiterhin
tests geben
für kinder unter zwölf ist ein
zugelassener impfstoff noch nicht
vorhanden und bei den über zwölfjährigen
bleibt die stiko noch zurückhaltend das
liegt auch daran dass bei kindern die
möglichen folgen einer infektion noch
nicht umfänglich erforscht sind etwa
beim thema lankowitz damit hat sich
sibylle bassler befasst
katharina weiß ganz genau wo und wie sie
sich mit dem corona virus angesteckt hat
bei einer bekannten am 29 oktober 2020
seitdem ist nichts mehr so wie es war
seitdem fühlt sie sich krank
[Musik]
ich kann mich halt mich konzentrieren
häufig würde ihr die krankheit nicht
geglaubt deshalb will die 15-jährige
nicht erkannt werden kann schule seit
monaten nicht zu denken
ihre einzige stütze ihre mutter ja sag
ich ganz froh weil es mir einfach nicht
geglaubt wurde dass ein mädel gibt es
nach corinna so schlecht gibt kam mir
vor wie eine aussätzige und total
hilflos mit herrn absoluter kranken kind
seit einiger zeit ist katharina in
behandlung bei dem internisten peter
elvinger sie ist kein einzelfall so der
mediziner
er behandelt über 30 jugendliche die
unter spätfolgen von kogit leiden in
meine praxis kommen viele eltern mit
jugendlichen weil sie nicht mehr wissen
wohin sie gehen sollen über anschauen
verschiedenen institutionen bei
verschiedenen ärzten leider war es so
dass viele eltern und jugendliche nicht
ernst genommen wurden doch wie häufig
kommen langzeitfolgen bei kindern und
jugendlichen vor
die antwort ist frustrierend man weiß es
nicht
eine der wenigen anlaufstellen für
betroffene ist die spezialambulanz des
heimischen kinderspitals hier steht man
erst am anfang der erkenntnisse über
longo wie bei kindern
fakt ist dass schwere verläufe einer
corona infektion bei ihnen seltener sind
doch immer wieder zeigen sich spätfolgen
gerade bei jugendlichen die symptome
sind vielfältig und diese schwere die
diagnose wie die therapie mit der
therapie muss man sagen haben wir im
moment noch sehr wenig was wir anbieten
können
da ist die forschung im moment
noch am laufen aber natürlich ist die
diagnostik auch sehr komplex und so
brauchen wir sehr viele spezialisten um
sowas auch vernünftig abklären zu können
die datenlage ist äußerst dünn
es existieren nur wenige
wissenschaftliche studien und deren
ergebnisse variieren erheblich die folge
die verunsicherung ist groß licht ins
dunkel kann jetzt eine studie der uni
kinderklinik erlangen bringen
im mrt sollen veränderungen in der lunge
sichtbar gemacht werden
durch aufwendige blutanalysen mögliche
schädigungen der zellen durch ko ried
bei jungen menschen dargestellt werden
bei kindern gibt es vielleicht auch
dinge die im organismus sich zeigen die
wir gar nicht richtig sehen können und
unsere studie versucht so neue
erkenntnisse darüber zu gewinnen welche
narben in der letzten eigens eine
infektion im körper von einem kind oder
einen jugendlichen
die mediziner hoffen so das
krankheitsbild longo witt bei kindern
und jugendlichen besser zu erfassen und
dadurch den betroffenen zu helfen und
katharina neun monate ihres lebens habe
sie durch corona verloren nach einer
langen leidensgeschichte
sehen sie sich jetzt nach normalität
nach einer rückkehr in den alltag und
die 15-jährige im september wieder ganz
normal in die schule gehen kann und
jetzt nochmal heinz da geht es zunächst
um die finanzielle seite der
hochwasserkatastrophe
die bundesregierung will verhindern dass
es hier nun eine pleitewelle von
unternehmen gibt sie hat deshalb ein
vorübergehendes aussetzen der
insolvenzantragspflicht für betroffene
firmen auf den weg gebracht weil er die
haller was bringt das für die firmen
es bringt vor allem zeit zeit bis die
geplanten hilfen für den wiederaufbau
der betroffenen unternehmen ankommen bei
uns geht es ja recht schnell mit der
insolvenz die muss ein unternehmen nach
drei wochen an
melden wenn rechnungen nicht mehr
bezahlt werden können ja und damit
solche firmen die eigentlich gesund und
in not geraten sind geschützt werden
soll die insolvenz pflicht ausgesetzt
werden und das gilt rückwirkend vom 10
juli bis ende oktober kann aber
verlängert werden bis maximal ende märz
nächstes jahr
voraussetzung die schieflage der
unternehmen muss auf flut schäden
beruhen die insolvenz pflicht
auszusetzen ist nicht ganz neu dieses
gesetz wurde schon nach der letzten flut
und auch in der korona krise eingesetzt
ja und da blieb die befürchtete
pleitewelle bisher weitgehend aus und
lässt sich schon abschätzen wie viele
unternehmen betroffen sind
nein es ist ziemlich schwierig da gibt
es noch keine konkreten zahlen die
industrie und handelskammer schätzt dass
tausende firmen betroffen sind direkt
und indirekt durch schäden an der
infrastruktur firmen in allen
größenordnungen geschäfte cafes betriebe
ganze fußgängerzonen wurden zerstört
oder stark beschädigt laut ihk gehen die
schäden in die milliardenschäden die
schwer nachzuweisen sind da viele
unternehmen sämtliche unterlagen
weggeschwommen sind das gesetz ist aber
eigentlich nur rechtliche begleitmusik
für finanzielle hilfen die nun möglichst
bald auf den weg gebracht werden sollen
bund und länder beraten kommende woche
über einen wiederaufbau von
bundesfinanzminister scholz hat eine
zahl in den raum geworfen er erwartet
mehr als sechs milliarden euro an
hochwasserschäden
das gesetz soll auch bald auf den weg
gebracht werden vermutlich in der
sommerpause bei einer sondersitzung des
bundestages
valerie haller vielen dank wenn sie den
menschen im katastrophengebiet helfen
wollen hier das spendenkonto des
aktionsbündnisses katastrophenhilfe
die iban lautet de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 stichwort zdf hochwasser weitere
informationen finden sie unter spenden
punkt zdf de und im zf text auf seite 8
190 und jetzt die zahlen vom lotto am
mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
135 46 30 41 und die superzahl 2 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text ab seite 557 das
was von uns beiden verbunden mit dem
hinweis auf das nachfolgende
auslandsjournal das heute ausführliche
berichte hat war die brände in den
europäischen ferienregion 0 30 gibt es
dann das heutige update mit wulf
schmiese
[Musik]
ein gut und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter derzeit brennt es nicht nur in
der mittelmeerregion sondern auch über
sibirien und das schon seit wochen
interessant ist jetzt dass der rauch
abtransportiert wird und zwar
ungewöhnlich weit in den norden der
jetstream läuft hier von süd nach nord
ist sehr schwach ausgeprägt und bringt
hier die warmen luftmassen in den norden
ja und der rauch von den bränden wird
mit gezogen und wird direkt über den
arktischen ozean geführt dass es eine
recht ungewöhnliche wetterlage
ungewöhnlich auch bei uns weiterhin die
tiefste über uns hinweg rauschen das
liegt an dieser struktur vom atlantik
über süd europa bis nach osteuropa und
es gelang immer wieder tiefs zu uns
dieses tief hat hier relativ viel regen
in norditalien und über dem über den
alpen gebracht und so wird es auch in
der nacht im süden deutschlands
weitergehen mit regen im norden ist auch
etwas ring dabei sonst ist es
überwiegend trocken bei tiefsten
temperaturen von neun grad im hessischen
bergland und 14 grad im westen
deutschlands
morgen tagesverlauf ziehen weitere
schauer und gewitter durch allmählich
nach osten von westen her lockert auf
mit etwas sonnenschein und auch im
nordosten gibt es sonne temperaturen
dazu dort 24 bis 25 grad an den alpen
bei 18 grad
ja und die nächsten tage weitere schauer
und gewitter sind unterwegs teilt auch
kräftige freitag bis 24 grad und am
samstag von westen erneut neue gewitter
auch kräftig und das bei 26 grad ein
schöner amt